America's most committed dog lover John
wick is back for another bone cracking
adventure which means we're back for
another round of Easter eggs references
and callbacks rest assured no dogs are
killed in this movie I mean hundreds of
people die but the dogs are all fine
probably first up let's talk he'll count
this is John wick second deadliest
outing so far if you just count people
he kills personally not everyone who
dies in the movie wick personally takes
out 94 people during John wick
Parabellum which is more than the 77
folks he straight-up murdered in the
first movie but both of them are
absolutely shattered by the John wick
chapter to kill count of 128 people the
new film picks up mere moments after
chapter 2 ended with John still
suffering from the knife wound he
received from Santino Don Tonio's
bodyguard Aires and the minutes ticking
away until he's declared officially XK
and considering the chapter 2 started
just four days after the events of John
wick that means the entire series has
unfolded in the course of about one week
this guy has earned a personal day note
that this is also the first film in the
wick series that doesn't feature John
Leguizamo as John's mechanic friend or
Elio he's still working on John's
Mustang which got beat to hell in the
first scene of chapter 2 my guess John
finally picks up the finished car at the
end of the last film a number of famous
and notable faces appear in John wick 3
only to have a fist a bullet or even a
book slammed through them moments later
the enormous assassin whom John takes
out with a heavy tome in the New York
Public Library is beau bond Marjanovic
the Center for the Philadelphia 76ers
I've been looking forward to meeting you
and so far you haven't disappointed
that's of course actor and martial
artist Mark Dacascos as one of John's
primary rivals throughout the film the
assassins 0 when he first appears he's
working along with his team as a sushi
chef a reference to Dacascos many years
playing the chairman on the American
version of Iron Chef today
secret ingredient is to of zeros
henchmen with whom John tangles with in
the film are played by Yahoo Yan and
cha-cha defragment these Indonesian
martial artists both appeared in the
modern action classic the raid - along
with the force awakens Yan Yan played
Street Fighter tasu leech while Rahman
played crew kind shunned
they're both members of the kanji club
gang who confront Han Solo on the
Millennium Falcon tracer leech
good to see you finally Keanu Reeves
very own martial arts instructor Tiger
Chen pops up briefly in the movie as a
member of the Chinese triads there are
so many little references and asides in
John wick 3 that they even fit one in
the title para bellum is Latin for
prepare for war and is specifically
mentioned by Winston in the film but
it's also been the name of a variety of
pistols and firearm cartridges over the
years let's see what they did there cuz
you know guns
speaking of which John's lying to
Winston that he needs guns lots of guns
is it direct call back to Neos request a
tank in the matrix good this film also
has a mood setting Lobby shootout and
fused with matrix s green lighting and
cased anyone missed the parallel John
goes to me one of the members of the
high table anjelica huston as the
mysterious director at a ballet company
known as the Turkish ski theater this is
a reference to the iconic Russian
filmmaker Andrei Tarkovsky now here's
something interesting
Wyck 3 Helmer chad stall ski co-directed
the first movie alongside david leitch
who later went on to make atomic blonde
and that movie also had a Tarkovsky
reference there's a big fight scene in
front of a movie screen where his epic
sci-fi film stalker is being projected
these guys just really like their
Tarkovsky shoutouts what can I say the
marquee announces that the company is
putting on a show called a tale of two
wolves which doesn't seem to be the name
of an actual ballet possibly it's a
reference to John wick himself who so
far in the series has owned two
different dogs there's also two dogs
owned by Halle Berry's character Sophia
who appears later in the movie maybe
this is foreshadowing while we're on the
subject of ballet quick question why do
so many movie assassins trained in
ballet schools
Black Widow red Sparrow John wick is
this an actual thing anyway if Stawski
has said that the big motorcycle chase
sequence was inspired by a similar scene
in the south korean action film the
villainous
[Music]
also while in Morocco hoping to find the
head of his entire high table criminal
organization John is told to walk into
the desert following canis minor this is
a star also known as the lesser dog of
course dog star was the name of Keanu
Reeves ban in the 1990s they were
actually pretty good
I'll make you a mixtape
Isabelle takes a while back as with
chapter 2 the third entry in the wick
series seems to end in a way that
directly leads to more sequels it's not
hard to imagine a new follow up in which
John now aligned with Laurence
Fishburne's Bowery King launches an
assault against Winston and the New York
Continental the fight could even spread
internationally and find John attempting
to bring down the high table itself this
has got to be this franchises endgame
right recall that John's home was
destroyed in Chapter two and he can't
stay at the Continental any more no
matter how many gold coins he has
stashed now that he's functionally
homeless perhaps John really will be
joining the Bowery gang full-time you've
also got to wonder how losing this
finger is going to potentially hold John
back in the future maybe he'll only be
able to take out 30 thugs at once
instead of 40 let us know if you think
this is going to be a major obstacle for
him in Chapter four and any other little
riffs or references we might have missed
keep them in the comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]